wonderful he doing good good this has to
feel good man it does yeah yeah this has
been an amazing experience how long's
this movie been in your life as a movie
not your life as a movie probably did
you realize that your life would
translate wonder that everything that
you guys went through would be this
great I think it was my writing
producing partner John Morris who said
one day why don't we do a movie about
that yeah and and then and I think it
was his idea to make it a comedy which
seemed like a weird idea at first but he
said you know so many of the stories
that you tell me are really funny so
that's where it really it started we all
have it at one point Earl I've sat with
friends where they're like hey man if
they ever did a movie about your life
who would play you and nobody has had
the balls to ever say Mark Wahlberg well
to be fair he's actually not playing me
it really is a the story is a fictional
tale that's inspired by yeah but yeah
you know I just tell everybody that I
said I wanted an ABS man for me as your
family's seen this yes yes a time what
was their take on it well they had been
hearing about it throughout the process
and I've been talking with my family so
much about it so they really knew every
stitch of it they had come to sad yeah
and of course many times met the kids
and so I think when they saw the movie
it just really felt like kind of a
family affair all the way through of the
I think they really felt their own
contribution to it when they saw it I'm
listening to somebody talk about
adoption almost seems very retro because
I remember when I was younger the idea
of adoption was very much at the
forefront you would hear much more about
it and now listening to you talk so much
about it doing press for this movie and
then the actual you know plot of the
movie it almost seems like yeah why
aren't we talking about this more is it
because there's just so much other stuff
that people are concerned with where
we've almost lost the interest in
adoption to be at the forefront of
conversation
yeah well and I think for a long time
when people heard the words adoption
their their minds went to you know
Madonna and Angelina Jolie and then sort
of overseas adoption and meanwhile we
have hundreds of thousands of kids
in our own country who are right now are
living in strangers homes and are living
in group homes and and who need really
good loving moms and dads and so I'm
really glad that this movie is is
hopefully going to get get on that topic
for a while right and have you heard
from other people who have adopted since
you came out with the movie
are you hearing those stories yet I was
similar to yours oh well I hear those
stories all the time cuz she talked to
me about it all the time but the most
gratifying thing is you know we had for
example there was a person who had seen
the movie at Paramount who came up to me
afterwards and she said you know my
husband and I we we got into the classes
we went down the road but we chickened
out and now that I've seen the movie I'm
gonna reengage and I think the reason
for that is because the movie paints a
more complete picture it it doesn't shy
away from the difficult parts of it but
it takes you to the parts of it where it
really is full of love and joy and
laughs and I will hold this movie up
against really any other names trying to
think of one where somebody has
assembled a cast of just the most
hysterically talented people yeah
they're funny do you have the funniest
cast I think I've seen a movie in years
oh thank you oh man I agree we have a
powerhouse cast cuz Octavia Spencer TIG
Notaro of course mark and Rose the kids
are all fantastic and margo martindale
and Julie Hagerty as the grandmothers
just come out and me yeah murder you're
right you're right that's everybody's
grandmother in that movie yes absolutely
thank you so much trying to really
appreciate their thank you take care